ninja what's your studio vibe like is it
low-key if like is everyone in there
kind of got to have a you know i'll
record at home a lot so i'll be on the
focus right still would you what are we
doing what's your interface at home oh
yeah i got the same [ __ ] bro is it focus
right same simple setup
it's a scarlet though actually scarlet
focus right yeah oh that's the same
thing yeah the red the red one yep
simple setup are you telling me i did
chosen on that
i mixed chosen it's on the radio i want
everyone to know
you have no [ __ ] excuse
because a focusrite scarlett is
two hundred dollars 250. yeah
depending on how many inputs you got you
got the two
the four
i got the two that's two
that's 250 maybe yeah at guitar center
right now what's the mic what's the
at-home mic i got a
i got a road mic
i had this road mic for like six years
you have a road mic yeah do you is it
just straight into the focus right or do
you have like a cloud lifter or anything
or straight
into the focus
i gotta update my system man but it's
working for me and you're recording you
record you recorded chosen on that mic
yeah
you didn't re-record it or anything nah
yep
this is amazing